حسنًا ، دعنا نتحدث عن بياناتك الجديدة
حول أول 100 يوم للرئيس بايدن
أه كيف تكدس مقارنة
بالرئيس السابق ترامب ،
لذا فهو بعيد عن الكمال ولكن لا
توجد أيضًا مقارنة ، لقد
أحصيت 29 ادعاءً كاذبًا من الرئيس
بايدن في أول 100 يوم له مرة أخرى  أنا
لا أقوم بإقامة حفلة للرئيس بايدن
لتقديم 29 ادعاءً كاذبًا ، لكن هذا
حوالي واحد
كل 3.5 أيام بالنسبة لترامب في أول
100 يوم له ، لقد أحصيت 214 ادعاءً كاذبًا ،
لذا فقد كانت حوالي اثنين أو أكثر في اليوم
وكانت تلك فترة بطيئة بالنسبة
ترامب براين في آه السنوات اللاحقة
مثل السنة التي عدتها كمراسل لشبكة سي إن إن
، كان متوسط ثمانية ادعاءات كاذبة في ال
وم ، لذا مرة أخ
ى بعدم الكمال ، هذه ليست مجاملة لل
ول إنه أفضل بكثير من ترامب لك
ها حقيقة أنه أفضل بك
ير من  الناس الرابحة ينسون أن ترامب
تدهور من حيث
أه دقته ساءت الأمور وأسوأ
وأسوأ على مدى السنوات الأربع ،
إليكم ما أعتقد أنه الأكثر إثارة للاهتمام
حول بايدن لقد لاحظته وقد
لاحظت أنه  يتأرجح عندما يتم التحقق من حقيقة
أنه يصحح مساره ،
لذلك تشير إليه أنت أو عوامل أخرى
تشير إلى أن شيئًا ما غير دقيق ،
فهو يتوقف عن قول ذلك في عدة
حالات مختلفة ربما ليس بالسرعة
الكافية
ولكن هذا فرق كبير عن ترامب
بايدن أو فريقه الذي يكتب نصوصه
يبدو أن رد الفعل على
التحقق من الحقائق هو أن
هذا صحيح في بعض الحالات على الأقل ، لذلك
هناك بعض الادعاءات الكاذبة أو المضللة
التي كررها بايدن دون تصحيح
ولكني أحصيت حالتين على الأقل قال
فيهما هو أو
فريقه شيئًا ما  خطأ ، لقد تحققت من
الحقائق وكذلك قام آخرون بفحصها على أنها
خاطئة
، ثم لم يقولوا ذلك مرة أخرى ، لقد
قاموا بتعديل لغتهم بشكل كبير
وأحد
الأمثلة البارزة هو أنهم
طرحوا خطة البنية التحتية الخاصة بهم بالقول إن هذا
سيخلق 19 مليون وظيفة
بايدن بنفسه  استخدمت صيغة أكثر
صحة قليلاً لكنها كانت
مضللة جدًا
وبعد ذلك عندما قلت أن هذا يبدو خاطئًا ،
فهذا مضلل ، لم يستخدموا ذلك أبدًا
19 مليون رقم مرة أخرى
في الواقع ، إنه أقرب إلى 2.7 مليون وظيفة ،
لذا مرة أخرى من الأفضل
ألا يخطئوا أبدًا في المقام الأول
.  يختلف كثيرًا
عما رأيناه في حقبة ترامب
حيث قد ترى الرئيس
يكرر نفس الادعاء الكاذب حرفياً مئات
المرات
على الرغم من أنه تم التحقق من الحقيقة ، فأنت
تعلم أن 30 من تلك المرات لم
يهتموا بها ،
نعم ، تركت نيكول 30 ثانية هذا التأثير
من اختيار ثقافة الأخبار الخاصة بك ،
كل هذه الأكاذيب المجنونة تخرج من الثعلب ،
إذا تجاهلناها فقط ، إذا
تجاهلنا
هذا الهراء جيدًا
، نعم ولا أعتقد أننا يجب أن نتجاهل
أنك تعرف الحالات الصغيرة
ونحاول عدم تضخيمها
ما نحن  يجب أن نفعل ذلك هو أننا يجب أن نعمل على
وضعها في السياق ،
فبدلاً من مجرد قول لا جو
بايدن لن يأتي من أجل الهامبرغر الخاص بك ،
يمكننا التحدث عن الدور الذي يلعبه الكذب
كخطاب
خطابي وسياسي
tegy لمحاولة تشويه سمعة إدارة بايدن وللتقدم
بنوع مختلف من السياسة
وأعتقد أن وضع السياق
هو طريقة أفضل بكثير للتعامل مع هذا الأمر
الذي يمنعنا من مجرد نشر أو
تضخيم
هذه القصص الكاذبة ، نعم ، دعونا نضيف قيمة على
الإطلاق
دانيال نيكول ، شكرًا لكما.